I are gonna start good morning everybody
thank you very much for coming along my
name is Brian Hogan can I get a little
show of hands of people who have heard
of poly before this is so much better
than previous conferences I've been to
and then of you that have heard of it
how many are using it okay a few less
and then I'm who's using retries
fallbacks fewer circuit breakers one Ian
bulkhead isolation no hands
yeah so that's kind of what we see it's
mostly retries in fallbacks
that's good to know I'm going to have my
Twitter handle up here if there's time
at the end I'm very happy to take
questions from the audience or if you
don't feel like it you can tweet them at
me if I can't answer them during the
session I will happily look at it later
in the day so poly for most of you who
are aware of it is an answer to a
problem that you have but those of you
that haven't heard of poly it may well
be the solution to a problem you're not
aware of so failures happen that can
happen to any application at any time
and they will happen to your application
so what do you do when something goes
wrong many of us are working on
applications that rely on connectivity
but connectivity has never ever been a
guarantee the old adage the network is
not reliable we also have to deal with
software errors some of us have to deal
with things like local network outages
and of course applications are now
spread out across the internet and you
have to deal again with unreliable
connections around the world any problem
along the way could lead to your request
failing if you're working on mobile
applications this is especially true so
what can you do if there's transient
fault or a longer outage in our system
that you rely on you could do this you
could drop a yellow screen and death
this might be okay if your application
if it doesn't matter to application that
you lose one request this might be
unacceptable if you're working in a
banking scenario but this might also
lead to cascading failures if you have
more and more failures question becomes
what can you do about a failure a
trapper to give you a transient fault
and retrying is the usual answer if
let's say you're building your own
little application and it depends on a
remote application retrying would look a
little like this you make your first
request and you got to fail your back or
you don't get a response
so you retry and you get another failure
and you retry and you get another
failure and then finally you get back
the response you were hoping for you
could keep at that an infinite number of
times but usually you are limited so how
would you program something like that
and I've asked this is this is a good
audience you're all using poly so you
know how to do it but when I've asked
this at conferences where people are not
using poly the answer usually looks
something like this if you're making a
request with a HTTP client you do it as
normal you put a for loop around us
retrying two three four five times
whatever suits you but you might get
exceptions so you need a try-catch along
the way you may have to catch multiple
types of exceptions or you might do a
catch-all with plain old exception and
then you have to break out of that loop
if you get a successful response people
have tried to convince me that this is
good enough and this is usable and
they're happy to do it but it's fragile
it's very very hard to use in multiple
locations it's difficult to change it's
hard to customize and of course it's not
what I would recommend
and here's the answer Pali Pali is a
resilience framework for dotnet and if
you are using Microsoft technologies it
is the only game in town if any of you
have worked in the Java world you may
have come across history history has
some of the features that Polly has and
has a few extra ones and Polly has some
more features that history does not have
Polly helps protect your applications
from failure but this has a knock-on
effect on downstream applications that
are calling you and on upstream
applications that you depend on it helps
all of them to remain stable when faced
with transient faults longer outages
excess load or other problems
Polly is able to do this true things
like retries wait and retries circuit
breakers I mentioned and a few other
features Polly was started in 2013 by
Michael Wolff Dhin Dhin but more
recently has been taken over by the
app-v next group and I think a few of
you saw how frankenz presentation
yesterday so Carol is part of that in
the last few years an English gentleman
team named Dylan Rison Berger has been
leading the project and doing an
enormous amount of development the Polly
project is active on github slack they
have their own blog and Dylan has been
on both my own podcast and a little more
recently on the dotnet rocks podcast
Polly works in all platform to dotnet
works on so think of how this might
applic help you up in mobile
applications embedded applications or
IOT for connectivity is more difficult
I'm going to show you all the code that
you need at the point of making a
request with Polly so forget about that
for loop forget about the try-catch
forget about the break this is all you
need to make a reliable request I'm
gonna use my little pointer so you have
your HTTP client making a request to
remote endpoint and you make the call
inside a policy that you've defined and
the policy is a Polly
try policy again at the point of the
request that is all the extra code you
need if you are pre dotnet core 2.1 you
do need to define the policy ahead of
time but you do that once for your
application what this policy says is
that it works with HTTP response
messages and if the status code you get
back is anything other than a success
code or there was an exception
you read throught retry up to three
times you still get back at HTTP
response message it doesn't interfere
with what you're getting back you don't
have to unwrap anything unbox anything
this is easy to reuse and it's very easy
to change and pass around but if you're
on dotnet core 2.1 that's all you need
at the point of making a request notice
how there is no reference to poly
there's no execute async you user HTTP
client as though poly wasn't there you
don't even have a using statement in
that class you don't have to pass the
policies around and this is all thanks
to HTTP client Factory I'm gonna have a
few slides on that a little bit later a
few years ago when I started work on a
plural side course on poly I couldn't
find any definitions of what a
resilience framework was so when you're
in that kind of position you come up
with your own and I have three points
the resilience framework actively
protects resources and restricts the
amount of memory threads sockets in use
and it makes use of caching and other
capabilities when possible it would let
you recover from a failure so things
like retrying weight and retrying but if
recovery is not possible it will
facilitate graceful degradation that
could mean failing quickly rotted and
slowly depending on your application
it might be in reducing the load on
yourself or an upstream application or
shedding load or
turning some sort of default it's very
context dependent on your own
application so what graceful degradation
means is for you to decide but again
think of how this might have upstream
and downstream effects I'm going to
repeat this a few times throughout the
talk as I want to kinda drill it in
because you make your own application
resilient you are helping those that
call you and the ones that you're
calling and you'll see examples as we go
true poly is broken into two broad
categories called resilience as arts we
call strategies there are reactive
strategies and proactive the reactive
strategies are the ones that most people
have used here to retry where you a
request make a request it failed and you
retry immediately a wait and retry which
as a name implies puts in a little bit
of a pause before the retry occurs a
circuit breaker this one cuts the
connection between your application and
a remote application that may be
struggling and a fallback this will
return something when everything else
has failed or it will take some action
that is of use to you
that could be paging someone sending an
email scaling out a system rebooting a
computer that's entirely up to you and
of course dependent on the context that
you're in
on the proactive side these ones monitor
ongoing events and attempt to prevent
problems before they occur they'll try
to stabilize your system and allow it to
fail more gracefully the first one to
use is a timeout this one lets you
decide when a request should not
continue you want it to stop after five
seconds instead of 20 seconds which
would be the default say for some
applications or for some libraries
you're using caching will store a
response for a period and then if
another request of the same kind with
the same parameters comes in Pali will
read from its cache return that rather
than make an outbound request and then
bulkhead isolation this one protects
resources so a failing part of your
application or a part that struggling
won't consume all the resources of your
application it won't consume all the
threads memory sockets database
connections file i/o whatever it happens
to be at the heart of Pali
are policies so the things that we've
been talking about retry timeouts
circuit breakers they're all policies a
policy is made up of two parts a handles
clause and a behavior clause so just to
remind you that's what the policy looks
like this is the handles clause it
specifies the conditions under which the
policy becomes active so in this case if
you get anything other than a success
code the policy is active and this is to
behavior clause so if I get back a 500
I'm going to retry up to three times we
want to retry more than that and I won't
retry if I get back a success code on
the first retry or the second retry as
you can see they are written in a fluent
style policies are also reusable a
single policy can be used in many parts
of your app
occasion you could pass it into
controllers with dependency injection
there's also a thing called a policy
registry which I will cover in a few
slides or with dotnet core 2.1 you can
pass it around via HTTP clients that
come out of a HTTP client factory
policies are thread safe so a single
policy can be used at multiple places at
the same time so if I've got a retry
making a request to github and I have a
retry making a request to Google the
counts are independent they don't
interfere with each other you can use a
single policy simultaneously in a
hundred places all policies support the
execution of delegates retry has an on
retry fallback has a non fallback which
allows you to perform another action
just before the retry executes so this
is very useful free authorization so
imagine you make a request you get back
on authorized there is very little point
in making the identical request three
more times you want to perform some sort
of reauthorization and I'll show you an
example of that shortly you can use
policies with both synchronous and
asynchronous code they come in two
flavors and policies can be wrapped what
this means is you could have a policy
inside a policy inside a policy which
then finally execute something like an
HTTP client request so an example might
be a retry which is retrying an HTTP
request the retry is wrapped by a
circuit breaker and the circuit breaker
is wrapped by a fallback so in a case
like that you'd make your request if it
fails you to retry a bunch of times if
they all fail the circuit breaker will
consider cutting the connection it may
not do so but then the fallback will
return some default for you for the rest
of the talk I'm going to be coming back
to this particular slide so this little
green piece of code is my representation
of our application that we're going to
be building for the next 40 minutes or
so
and I'm gonna try to build a picture of
a fault-tolerant application that can
stand up to the kind of failure as we
talked about it start the first thing I
think we need is the ability to make
robust requests so in the event of a
problem with a remote system my
application should retry I may want to
be guaranteed to get a response even
when there's a failure that isn't always
the case but I want the ability to do
that I want to be able to cut the
connection to a remote system that's
failing or responding too slowly because
I'm gonna reduce load on it and help it
and I'm also going to help myself
I would prefer to fail quickly rather
than slowly why take a hundred seconds
to fail when you know you're gonna fail
after one second again I'm going to
reduce local resource use I'm gonna help
my downstream system that's calling me
and I may help in upstream system if I
can use a cache for requests that are
the same within a short period again I'm
going to help myself and help all the
applications around me and then I should
also protect my own resources so that
one part of my application can't do
damage to other parts of my application
so an example might be you're getting
incoming requests that you need to make
outbound requests for and you're getting
thousands and thousands of them and that
part of your application is now going to
suck up all your sockets and you won't
have any sockets left for a different
part of your application we can prevent
that with poly I this slide is going to
be a quick overview of how a general
request works yeah most of this is HTTP
clients oriented but it applies to other
types of things to make a request check
if it's a success if it is you return
your nice response if it's a failure you
still return a response and you may have
to handle it in some fashion maybe you
do maybe you don't
maybe you're happy to return to 5-under
to your caller with Polly it'll change
slightly so we make our request as
normal we check its response Polly will
kick in if it's a failure Polly will
then determine whether or not you should
perform a retry so I might say I'm only
gonna retry five hundreds I'm not gonna
retry unauthorized if I am going to
retry then I'm gonna make a request
again if that one happens to be a
success I return my response if the
retry fails I come back to Polly I check
again whether or not I should perform a
retry you may because again the failure
might be one that you're handling or you
may not because you might have already
hit the limit of retries and you're
going to give up and you return a
response Polly doesn't interfere with
the flow of a request when it succeeds
or when it fails it's only when it's a
condition under which it should be
active but having said that it
interferes it doesn't do anything to the
response it doesn't change it in any
fashion it's only that it will retry it
in the fashion in in some form and as I
said earlier you can use a single policy
to concurrently make hundreds and
hundreds of requests and it don't
interfere with each other in any way but
there's a problem with retrials and it's
this if the system you're calling is
failing because it's already overloaded
and you're going retry retry retry retry
retry you're not helping you're not
giving it any chance to recover and
you're gonna overload it even more and
it's gonna take longer for that that
system to to get to a point of
responding to you
but you're also making life worse for
yourself you've got lots of open sockets
lots of threads lots of memory in use a
slightly better solution is to use the
wait and we wait and retry policy you
make your request and you pause if it's
a failure you pause that say for two
seconds and you retry if that's a
failure you pause for four seconds now
you're giving that remote system a
chance to recover and you're also not in
any way using up your resources at a
very high rate and then you might wait
eight seconds and then finally sixteen
seconds you can choose any algorithm you
want for that delay it's a little lamb'
that which I'll show you in a moment so
you can do it as one second two seconds
three seconds some to ^ that I use in
this case and as I said this gives the
remote system a chance to recover if any
of you have done networking you might
know Ethernet uses something like this
when packet collisions occur there's a
small problem with this if you are
making thousands of outbound requests to
our mote system or hundreds even and
they're all suddenly failing and then
all your requests are waiting and
retrying at the exact same rate then
you're going to be sending out hundreds
requests at zero seconds and at two
seconds and at four and it whatever it
is 816 but what you can do is in little
lambda to determine how long you should
pause before making a retry you can put
jitter in so you could say two seconds
four seconds eight seconds plus or minus
random number no greater than 300
milliseconds and now all of them are
going to back off at slightly different
rates so the likelihood of you hammering
that remote system is reduced
I want to show you a little bit on how
the two of them look so we looked at a
basic retry earlier this one is one less
line so it's a retry policy and its
handling HTTP response messages if the
status code I get back is not a success
code I retry up to three times the
weight and retry looks almost identical
same condition if it's not a success
code I wait and retry up to three times
and in this case I'm going to delay and
this is my little piece of code for my
delay so you can see you could choose
any algorithm you want for the weight
and retry if you're on deck or 2.1 and
beyond you're probably going to use HTTP
client factory in dependency injection
so you're probably gonna define your
policies with ia sync policy as opposed
to the named type but for the rest of
the presentation to make it easier to
read so isn't IA sync when you're
looking at it I'm gonna stick with the
the Defiant type so I'm gonna use
retries instead of IA syncs but you know
it would be the slightly better approach
for a real program I mentioned earlier
that reauthorization is a particular
case with retries you don't want to
retry if you guess 401 back you need to
do something and this is where the on
retry delegate comes in so the start of
it is the same I'm checking if it's not
a success code I'm gonna retry three
times but this is my own retry delegate
and I can get a little bit more granular
now the on retry delegate this
particular one requires me to pass in
the response and the retry count I'm not
going to use to retry count in this case
but I check the status code of the
response and if it is unauthorized I
perform some retry lot sorry give me
some reauthorization logic
of course it's up to you to decide what
that is it could be getting a new cookie
renewing a jar grabbing something from a
database but then your next request will
now hopefully be reauthorized performing
reauthorization when you're using HTTP
client factory is more complicated I
have an example on my blog and they'll
be links at the end or you can quite
easily find them on Twitter I'm gonna
give a very quick overview of how the
general policies work and Emery I won't
be showing these kind of slides again as
we saw Polly only gets involved when
there's a failure it will determine
whether or not it should perform some
action and if it should it takes that
action in most cases like we've talked
about it would be a retry bin other
cases it could be cutting a circuit it
could be sending a fallback it could be
cutting communications shedding load
those kind of things so request checks
the success code should I get involved
should my policy get involved no let the
request continue returning to failure
yes my policy should get involved take
some action at some conferences people
have asked me can I use poly for other
things and I hadn't I hadn't included a
slide like this up until a few months
ago and yes you can you can use poly for
any type of code you execute you can
execute any method you want with it in
this case I'm executing some error-prone
code that returns a number I'm executing
it inside retry policy and the retry
policy says that it's going to expect an
INT if the int is not zero or a / 0
exception occurs retry three times so
you can use poly for any type of
execution you want another little
example in this case I'm going to look
for some sort of job status
I expect an enum back if my enum isn't
valid
then I wait and retry and then a final
one would be I'm going to execute some
code that's going to an exception
probably and all I have to do is handle
an exception and I'll retry it three
times you can use poly with database
requests with file IO with connections
to the cloud anything you want
I'm airily use it for HTTP requests
because that's what I work on mainly API
to API communication but it will work
with anything alright back to our little
application so we've achieved what I
would say is robust requests so our
applications getting a little bit more
fault tolerant on to the next one so
fall backs are the policy that you're
probably going to use last if you're
using them in a wrap especially are
gonna be at the outside you could use
them with retries you could use them
with caches you can use them with
circuit breakers you can use them pretty
much with anything but it's almost
always going to be the very last policy
you use it can be used to return a
default it can be used to return a
cached value but poly has its own cache
so that's probably not the vesting but
it can as I said earlier it can be used
to perform an arbitrary function Trudy
on fallback delegate so you could paid
someone scalar system reboot a system
scale up a database anything of that
nature you aren't limited to just
returning some default or some sort of
response it's code
it's very simple I've changed the
condition on the poly clause here so I
remember I used to have if it's not a
success code you can say if it's not an
internal if it's an internal server
error you could take any type of
condition you want under which the
policy becomes active the policy is
named here and in this case what I'm
doing is I'm creating a HTTP response
message and I'm using a little bit of
cached data to return so I build the
HTTP response subject hype okay
put some content into it and I return it
so if I make an if I execute a request
with the fallback and I get a failure
then instead I'm returning my own HTTP
response broader than the 500 or the 404
or whatever I got back from the remote
system that's all there is to the
fallback circuit breaker I circuit
breaker is in the US it's like what we
call circuit breakers in our homes in
Ireland and Britain that they're
referred to as trip switches I don't
know what to refer to us here but it's a
thing that would cut electricity in your
home if there's a short-circuit or
something like that so in the same way
this has a closed condition closed is
the condition you want that is like an
electrical circuit current flows when
it's closed or like a pipe if there's no
holes in the pipe the water flows but
it's easier to stick with the electric
analogy when the circuit is open no
requests flow again if if you have two
wires and are not connected and no
electricity will flow but this has a
half-open stage and this is a test stage
after a circuit has been opened for a
period it will move to half open and
that is then when a test is performed we
have two kinds of circuit breaker an
original circuit breaker and an advanced
circuit breaker the original circuit
breaker is a simple sum of the
consecutive failures so if you get two
exceptions or two 404s
then it breaks a circuit no minimum true
put required nothing like that the
advanced circuit breaker looks at a
percentage of failures
excuse me over time and it has a minimum
threshold that needs to be met before it
becomes active circuit breaker has a way
of moving around itself it starts as
closed if you get a significant number
of failures or the required number of
failures it becomes open
and no more requests are allowed true
the circuit breaker the circuit breaker
will immediately an exception to
the caller so again its immediate the
caller doesn't have to wait around to
find out there's a problem from the open
state the circuit breaker can move to
half open as I said that's a test stage
the first request true to half open if
it works the circuit will move to closed
but if it fails the circuit goes back to
open for another period if it's been
open for a period the circuit will move
back to half open and that our test
would be performed and then finally the
move to closed and your your uh your
your request will flow as normal if I
have let's say an application that's
using poly and it's connected to
multiple remote applications and each of
those has remote multiple endpoints I
can use a circuit breaker to protect a
single endpoint a group of endpoints or
potentially all outbound requests from
my application but that would be unusual
that would mean you have some serious
network problems it would be better to
deal with
circuit breaker policies work a little
differently than all the others so with
a retry as I said you can make hundreds
of requests using a single policy and
they won't interfere with each other or
share any states but that is not what
you want with a circuit breaker you want
circuit breaker to share State across
multiple requests so it can track the
failures across all of them if you get
that aggregate number of failures across
all those requests then you want to cut
the circuit this is easy to do with a
single application because it's running
in process I can go or there's been one
failure two failures three failures cut
the circuit but many of us are using
multiple instances of an application
that's running on containers and they
somehow need to track those failures
also I'll come to that in a moment but
I'm going to show you briefly how to
write the policy as I said there were
two types of circuit breaker an original
circuit breaker and what the first one
says is that if I get two consecutive
failures in a 60 second window I'm going
to cut my circuit then I have three
delegates on break on reset and a half
open which I can use to perform
arbitrary logic or do some logging send
some telemetry or anything you like
the advanced circuit breaker says that
if 50% of my requests in a 30-second
window with a minimum true put of seven
requests in that 30 second window are
failure so half my requests are failures
in a 30-second window with a minimum
true put then I cut the circuit so it's
a little more fine-tuned probably a
little bit more usable for arcing that
for most people scenarios and it also
supports on break on reset and on half
open it's your choice to pick whichever
one is more suitable and very much
depends on your scenarios I mentioned a
moment ago that you could also have a
distributed circuit breaker so this was
what we looked at with a single process
making requests
but if you had something like this
multiple instances of your application
running on containers running an AWS for
the circuit breaker to function
correctly all the instances of your
application need to share data how many
times is an endpoint failed in the last
minute what's the total number of
failures have I had enough true put you
need somewhere to store that information
this feature is either been released
this week or it's coming very very soon
and it uses what's called Azure durable
functions it lets you store state
increment a number that could be read by
all instances of Pali so think of it as
a very trivial method that's got a an
add one or something like that and then
you can read so you can increment the
count any of the instances of your
application can say I've had a failure
in current apply one I've had a failure
incremented by one they all are aware of
the total number of failures and then
they can all cut the circuit it's not
much use if only one or two of them are
cutting the circuit our rights our
application now is able to isolate
itself from faulty upstream applications
the circuit breaker prevents you from
making requests a struggling remote
systems but it also immediately informs
the callers that their request can't be
completed when the circuits cut so again
Polly is having an effect on upstream
and downstream applications quick
summary of our reactive strategies we
had retry we fries immediately wait and
retry puts opposing circuit record cuts
the connection and fallback returns some
sort of default I mentioned that you can
combine these if you would have let's
say an HTTP request at the center you
could perform three retries in the event
of a failure
you could outside that have a circuit
breaker and if all that fails you could
return a retry so Polly allows you to
build up policies based off of other
policies
I'm going to do a little demo it's quite
trivial I'm gonna have two screens up on
the left is gonna be my local
application which is making requests to
my remote application my remote
application is unstable from most of the
things I'm going to request it's going
to fail three-quarters of the time now
we're going to see some printouts on the
screen showing what happens so I'll talk
you through it as I do it okay I hope
that text is legible but I'll talk you
through it again on the left is my local
application it's using Holley on the
right is a damaged application which
fails a lot so I'm gonna make a request
to my local application so what happened
here was the remote application receives
a request from the local failed the
local application retried remote remote
application failed back and forth back
and forth back and forth until the fort
request worked and about a response I'll
show that to you again because the speed
of it is quite quick happens very very
fast so again it's a remote application
needs time to recover that will not help
you instead I'm now going to do a wait
and retry so my local application makes
a request to the remote if it works I'd
get a response if it failed I'm gonna
retry the delays are getting a little
bit longer with each retry so the first
retry waited two seconds the second
waited for the sorry waited eight
this one uses a fallback the remote
application is going to fail a hundred
percent of the time this one in this one
so now we're making our third retry in a
moment it's gonna fail again but I got
back a useful okay
I chose zero as my default fallback
response so my application can continue
it doesn't have to deal with a failure
I'm saying zero in my case is a useful
response it's up to you to figure out if
that works for you and then one final
one which is just to show you that for
loops and tri caches work so this is one
where I had a for loop to try catch and
it works very quickly but it's brittle
and hard to use is my demo right oh yes
a couple of other things before we move
on to reactive strategies poly has a
thing called a registry we've seen a few
policies so far retry way to retry
fallback and circuit breaker if you
don't want to define them every time you
can put them inside a registry it's
effectively a store for those policies
it is a dictionary so it has all the
methods and features of a dictionary you
can pass it around through dependency
injection so you could create 1012
policies in your startup put them into
the policy registry put that into your
service collection and then send that
around your application as needed they
are reusable the registries and they
work with HTTP client factory which is
quite important as I will show you in a
moment
this is what a policy registry looks
like it can be individual policies or
wraps policies and they all get names
string names so you named your retry or
maybe your easy to be retry
how many of you are using HTTP client
factory very oh maybe a quarter of the
audience HTTP client factory came out I
think about a year and a half ago in
dotnet core 2.1 it was spring of 2018
what it provides is better lifetime
management if you're using HTTP client
by itself you've got two problems that
you face you if you're using a single
HTTP client for all your requests which
you can do you can end up with DNS
problems because if an IP address of a
remote host fitted changes your single
HTTP client won't know about it but you
can also end up with socket exhaustion
sorry to me that's if you're using a
single HTTP client but if you're using a
new HTTP client for every single request
you can end up with socket exhaustion so
imagine you've got hundreds of quests
coming in you're making hundred requests
going out new HTTP client new HTTP
client you can end up with the problem
with sake exhaustion it has happened
that my company on a couple of occasions
I mentioned a DNS renewal the other
wonderful thing about HTTP client
factory is that it integrates very very
tightly with poly you can use a policy
registry as I just showed you and then
you can use an arbitrary piece of code
like a function which could be made up
of if else's are scarce switches to pull
the policy from that registry based on
the request you're making and there's
there are two ways to use the history be
fine factory with poly
you would start off with your service
collection I hate you to be kind factory
it's only a few lines of code you could
add a single retry policy to your HTTP
client factory but if you're adding just
a retry policy that's fine if you're
doing nothing but gets if you're doing
posts puts you may have problems if your
retrying posts especially because of
idempotent concerns
but you can use httpclient factory with
a policy registry so you could put in
three four five ten policies and then a
little piece of code to pull out the
right policy based on the request and
you can base it on the URL or the verb
or some combination of those or any
other arbitrary condition you want quite
often you'd use a retry forgets maybe a
wait and retry four puts and you might
use what's called a no op policy for
posts no op is a pass through it does
nothing to the request the code would
look something like this configure
services in your startup class in dotnet
core you would add your policies I'm not
going to show them here you'd add them
to the registry you'd register the
registry with your service collection
and then this is all you need for a HTTP
client factory so if it was you that
haven't used it
I'm naming this factory as the remote
server factory I'm giving it a base
address and a default header and then
I'm saying use a policy selector method
to pick policies from a registry and
this is what the policy selector looks
like it gets passed in the registry and
the request is occurring at that moment
so every time you make a request it'll
pass
true here everything to make HTTP client
requests it'll pass through here if I'm
making a get request it's gonna pull
that names policy from my registry if
I'm making a post it's going to pull
them know up from my registry and if I'm
using if it's any other type of request
I'm gonna pull the wait and retry so
this gives you great flexibility for
pulling the right policy for the right
type of request but you define it in
your startup you don't need to do it at
the point that you're making the request
and then you can change it as you see
fit
that is all I have on here be kind of
factory another topic that comes up is
testing people ask of course that's a
different type of problem and I have a
blog post about us it isn't to do with
poly as such but take a look at my
broader blog and it's something that
came up recently it's relatively
straightforward the questions are if you
didn't hear it was how would you change
the headers in HTTP for a request using
HTTP client factory if you wanted to do
it dynamically then there is a way for
for testing testing has two general
scenarios you may want to test your code
as though you're not excuse me as a no
policy exists in that case you would
inject and no op so you can do your unit
tests but instead of using a retry you
would inject a no op if you're using a
registry you would swap you put in no
ops instead of retries wait retries and
so on the other thing you want to test
is how does your code react if polly
chose one of its exceptions like a
broken circuit exception or a timeout
rejected exception and to do that you
would use mocking this is a talk about
building resiliency but in the last week
or two Polly the Pali team have released
what is called a chaos engine and I'm
going to very very quickly show you that
it now supports fault policies which
allow you to inject exceptions at a
particular rate and you can turn them on
and off you can inject latency again at
a rate and turn them on or off you have
to fight you know I need any duration
you want or you can inject any behavior
so you could drop a database leave the
table cut a connection it is called
Simmi
you can do if you have access to your
own business logic you can put this code
into the business logic if you don't
let's say you're calling github and you
want to simulate failures you can use
these policies inside your HTTP requests
so that they would into
fear with the inbound responsive would
fail a certain number of times but this
talk is not about breaking stuff all
right let's move on to proactive
strategies to provide the strategies
monitor ongoing offense
screaming events attempt to prevent
problems before they occur
are they stabilizer system or they let
it fail gracefully and that varies
depending on your scenario there is a
timeout which lets you decide when a
request should end rather than whatever
the default of the tool you're using is
caching which would store a response for
a period and it returns that response
rather than making the external outbound
requests and then finally bulkhead
isolation which protects your resources
so one part of your own application
can't bring down the rest the timeout
policy so if your request goes
unanswered
it will timeout the choice is up to you
how that happens with HTTP client client
the timer could be as long as 100
seconds but most of us know if you don't
get a response within you know half a
second a second it's probably never
going to respond but if you're holding
on to that request for 100 seconds
you're holding memory holding the
sockets you're holding threads and of
potentially a downstream system is
waiting for you to respond because they
might not be using poly timers the
solution is the timeout policy this lets
you specify how long your request will
wait if no response is received and if
no response is received within the
period you define poly chose a time out
rejected exception this can be wrapped
inside other policies or outside them as
you see fit
like a retry policy it also supports a
cancellation token which will help you
clean up resources that you wonder why I
would try that are in use also timing
out quickly means your application isn't
wasting resources it's a it's a very
easy to use one and quite often
overlooked and this is how easy it is to
use
this says that if you're using this
policy and you don't get a response
within one second time it out all right
that is failing quickly I do have a
little bit of code that demonstrates to
us so in this case my application will
again make four requests to the remote
application the remote application will
respond but very slowly my application
is set to timeout I think after one
second so you're going to see on the
left side my application timing out on
the right side you're going to see the
remote application pausing thinking
about what to do eventually responding
but I don't get those responses so on
the left side you see it's delaying but
on the right side I'm performing my
retries but the retries are only allowed
to take a second and nothing ever comes
back so as far as I'm concerned the
requests failed but you can see on the
right side the responses were eventually
sent so you have to pick a timeout that
is appropriate one second was too short
because I set the remote server to pause
I think for five seconds and what you
get then is timeout rejected exception
okay our application is getting more and
more robust cashing a cash policy can be
wrapped around any other policy that
you're using or it can be used by itself
The Clash's store values can be used in
multiple places not just at the point
you make the initial request so you may
make a remote request remote server to
get some data but you can use that cash
elsewhere in your application you can
choose to cash the full HTTP response or
adjust a business data that's up to you
and I have a bunch of examples on the
blog about that how it works is a little
bit more complicated so in configure
services you define the cash in this
case it's a memory cache you set a
relative time to live in this case I've
set 30 seconds you can choose different
types of timeout you can have absolute
timeout sliding-window result TTL so
result TTL is great if you're using
something like a jot and it comes with a
HTTP response header that has a timeout
you define poly context and what you'll
notice here is that I'm saying I've got
a static part of it defined and then
I've got a dynamic part so I'm storing
something in my cache which is a
combination of these two names so it'll
be get by inventory ID number five ten
fifteen so if I get a request for the
same one I'll read from the cache if
it's not in the cache I'll go to the
outside service and then this is how you
use it you say cache policy that
executes a sync and then you do the HTTP
client request it's difficult to use the
cache with HTTP client factory this is
something that I've taught with Dylan
about and they're probably not going to
change it so if you want to use cache
you're better off to use policy registry
put it into that house the registry into
your controller or whatever code and
then raft
call to your httpclient just like that
this example shows the caching of the
whole HTTP response you can as I said
cache just a business data it's a little
more complicated but I wrote a
three-part series on my blog on how to
do that and also how to selectively
cache so this will cache if you get a
failure to but it's not trivial to do it
to only cache if you get to hundreds as
I said I have an exam I have a bunch of
examples on how to do the selective
caching and how to cache business data
only so please take a look at that
because it's a cache it has all the
standard methods you would expect from a
cache like on cache get on cache miss
put error and so on okay we're getting
more and more resilience with our
application and we're down to the final
thing on protecting resources but this
is what happens if your application
can't handle all the incoming requests
memory will be used up threads and
sockets are going to be held and this
can bring down your whole application
but it could also affect downstream
applications because they're making
requests to you they're expecting you to
respond you're not responding they're
holding on to memory they're holding on
to sockets and that can have as I say a
broader effect the term bulkhead
isolation comes from the nautical world
so if any of you have sailed boats or
done work on large ships you'll know
that they're broken into bulkheads that
are isolated so if I was to puncture a
part of the ship here this would flood
but hopefully the other parts wouldn't
flood so the same analogy if one part of
my application is having trouble
hopefully I can protect the other parts
of the application from getting into
trouble and my whole application or my
ship will not sink
how it would look I'm gonna go back to
this little local and remote example if
I have a local application that's
calling a remote application making
requests one request two requests no
responses yet I get one response it's
good I never get the second response now
I have one request hanging out holding
on to memory holding on to threads I
make a couple of more requests I only
get one response now I have two
outstanding requests I make a couple
more requests I only get one response
now I have three so imagine this
continuing on and on and I'm holding on
to these resources and I'm only getting
some of my responses back eventually my
application will fail if you're doing
this as a high-enough wait there's not
much else that will happen it will bring
down your application so this is what
the Pali bulkhead looks like it's made
up of two parts execution slots and
queue slots as an implies execution
slots are where requests are executed
and queue slots are where you store the
next requests that are going to be
executed let's say I get three incoming
requests there were nothing there with
none of the slots were in use those
incoming requests are immediately put
into execution slots and start executing
now let's say before those three or any
of those three complete I get six more
requests they cannot go into execution
slots so they go into the queue slots
now I've got three ongoing requests and
six queued requests I cannot take any
more requests but one comes in anyway
that will be rejected with an exception
immediately the system that calls me
will get a bulkhead exception
immediately it'll no I cannot handle
another request so it can do whatever
throttling that it needs to perform and
my application doesn't suck up more
resources because I'm never going to
have more than some specified number of
execution spots I'm probably helping the
upstream system too by not overloading
it so again I'm helping my own
application the downstream application
gets errors immediately and the upstream
application is being I'm throttling my
requests to the option application so
again resiliency is at wire across the
spectrum let's say one of my execution
starts freeze up great one of my queued
requests again one of my queued requests
we'll move to the execution slot and now
I can take another incoming request and
the same process continues I'll only
execute a certain number I'll only queue
a certain number I'm only going to take
up a certain amount of resources and
nothing more
bizarrely for a complicated thing it's
written extremely simply I'm saying that
this handles HTTP responses I've got
three execution spots six cute slots and
then this is a delegate that I can use
in the event that everything is full and
you can use that for logging for scaling
for anything you want how this would
look across a whole application would be
something like this let's say your
applications up and running and let's
pretend that whatever amount of memory
threads and sockets we have left is a
hundred percent in a way obviously it
won't be that or the whole computer but
let's say it's a hundred percent of what
will be available and let's say I've got
12 different bulkheads it would look
something like this
as you're getting requests coming in to
various parts of your application you're
going to limit how much of the overall
memory threads sockets any part of that
application is going to use so no matter
what happens within your application you
should be able to contain the amount of
memory and the amount of resources so
that you'll never run out and hopefully
your application remains stable all
right that is the last thing that we
needed for our little application so
hopefully we have a fault tolerant
resilient application if you want more
information I have a plural side course
on this I updated it eight or nine
months ago to include information on
HTTP client Factory
it has examples of all of these I have a
blog with far more examples and more
more and slightly newer stuff
particularly the caching one is
something a lot of people that was
asking me about there is an active slack
channel I'm on it from time to time
Dylan is on it all the time Dylan the
gentleman who is running the project at
the moment from the code perspective
Steve Gordon and a few other people I
some of you may know Steve he does a lot
of writing on HTTP client Factory there
is a github that you can raise issues on
you can contribute if you can that would
be wonderful
they're always looking for contributors
and then they have a blog as well I'll
put this slide up again in a moment for
you
I want to thank you all for coming out I
will stick around for questions or
anyone wants to know anything else but
other than that it is a wrap thank you
very much thank you